[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8 dont
nous ferons ensemble un tour de
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
le sommaire de ce vendredi 6 septembre
vous vous souvenez de ces images de
poissons morts asphyxiés dans la scène
suite à l'incendié de la station
d'épuration d'achères une réunion de
bilan sur la pollution a eu lieu hier
après-midi avec tous les acteurs
les cloches ont sonné c'est l'heure de
la rentrée plus de trois cent mille
élèves ont retrouvé le chemin de l'école
dans les yvelines
nous ferons le plan grenelle des
violences conjugales nouveau label pour
le signer cet élan cours et menace de
sécheresse dans les yvelines
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué
cette semaine le 3 juillet dernier s'est
déroulé l'incendié de la station
d'épuration d'achères fumée noire
poisson asphyxiés dans la scène deux
mois après une réunion d'information
s'est tenue en sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye pour dresser un
bilan
les précisions de manon bras manon 20
aldo et mathilde 2000
rappelez-vous suite à l' incendie de la
station d'épuration d'achères survenu le
3 juillet dernier des poissons asphyxié
des anguilles ou des perches morte
flotter est derrière moi
aujourd'hui deux mois après tout a été à
ramasser au total 7,5 tonnes ont été
enlevés de la scène deux mois après
l'eau de la seine est plus propre la
qualité bactériologique des eaux est au
moins aussi bonne qu auparavant
suite à l'incendié dont la cause n'est
pas encore connu la capacité de
traitement de l'usiné de seine aval
s'est réduite
l'incendié a touché les yvelines et le
val d'oise les élus restent très inquiet
notamment en cas de nouvel épisode
pluvieux et dans la mesure où sa
capacité de traitement aujourd'hui et
est atteinte en risque de se retrouver
malgré tout avec des problèmes assez
sérieux
dans la période qui vient dans les deux
ou trois ans qui viennent le siaap a
débuté son travail pour que l' usine
seine aval retrouve une capacité proches
de la situation existante avant
l'incendié
on sera prêt en tous les cas avant la
période estivale puisque là on a plus de
danger de mortalité dans la scène de
poisson déjà les mesures qui ont été
prises sont suffisantes et surtout on va
passer de 100 mètres cubes des débits de
la scène à 300 mètres cubes avec des
eaux qui était à 27 degrés au mois de
juillet qui vont être à 10 15 degrés
donc une capacité d'auto curation de la
scène importante qui préservera la vie
biologique du fleuve les travaux de la
reconstruction de l'unité débuteront en
2021 après une phase de nettoyage et de
diagnostic
le coût de la reconstruction est estimé
entre 80 et 100 millions d'euros une
réunion d'information s'est tenue à la
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
une troisième réunion d'information
suite à l incendie de la station
d'épuration d'achères survenu le 3
juillet dernier
aujourd'hui deux mois après un point
ressort de cette réunion
de nouvelles dispositions d'alert des
populations justement le préfet des
yvelines jean jacques brot s'est
positionné le pays le plan particulier
d'intervention a été présenté aux
différentes communes
une signature est prévue en septembre
concernant ce pays je le rappelle le
plan particulier d'intervention
une réunion se déroulera le 11 septembre
en sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye à 14h30
[Musique]
on a fait les fournitures va c'est la
page de garde des cahiers qu'on a
rencontré tous les we lundi c'était la
rentrée scolaire trois cent cinq mille
deux cent trente élèves ont enfilé leurs
cartables dans les yvelines
point sensible pour chaque académie les
ouvertures et fermetures de classes
cette fermeture pour dix neuf ouvertures
le nouveau directeur académique
antoine destrés dresse un bilan positif
cependant des parents d'élèves se sont
mobilisés à versailles-satory
sartrouville croissy-sur-seine bucs et
rambouillet particulièrement au collège
de rondo de cette dernière commune où
les postes de conseiller principal
d'éducation a été supprimée avec moi en
plateau frédéric heitz président
académique du snalc versailles le
syndicat national des lycées et collèges
bonjour bonjour alors côté enseignants
du secondaire quel bilan dressez-vous de
cette rentrée eh bien je dirais que
c'est une rentrée chaotique
cette année encore et à cao aggravé en
particulier pour les lycées mais pas
seulement
mais parce que justement la remise en
place de la réforme du lycée a aggravé
la situation qui était déjà difficile
dans beaucoup d'établissements manque
d'heures manque d'encadrement de
personnel et à cela s'ajoute l'explosion
de l'enseignement de spécialité
cette réforme on va y revenir mais parce
que du point de vue des enseignants on
va parler de leur rentrée à eux qui
était la semaine dernière pour tout
préparer plus de 19000 enseignants dans
les yvelines dont 361 stagiaires une
toute première rentrée pour où il était
accueilli mercredi 28 août à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines par la rectrice et le directeur
académique de versailles
ce dernier a répondu aux questions de
grégory canal et dans le 7-8 journal
surtout les accompagner tout au long de
l'année donc on l'aura expliquer un peu
comment ça coup cet accompagnement se
ferait donc au t2 lynn spence
institut de formation et puis évidemment
sur sur le terrain puisqu'ils partagent
leur temps entre moitié sur le terrain
moitié moitié à l'école oui donc et on
les accompagne
il ya vraiment je l' ai découvert un
accompagnement de qualité de la part des
tous les formateurs pour que le but
c'est qu'ils soient tous titularisés à
la fin d'année sur toutes les élèves
apprennent tous dans de bonnes
conditions et des jeunes professeurs en
formation qui sont de moins en moins
nombreux d'après une étude du conseil
national d'évaluation du système
scolaire plus de cent mille candidats se
présentaient aux écrits pour devenir
professeur du secondaire dans les années
90 ils sont aujourd'hui moins de 40
milles alors on parle parfois de crise
de vocation comment peut-on expliquer
cela frédéric reiss lectrice de
vocations s'explique aisément par la
rémunération des professeurs qui est de
moins en moins attractive qui fait que
certaines disciplines on cite les
mathématiques mais peut parler d'autres
notamment des lettres des lettres
classiques qui ne trouvent plus
suffisamment d'étudiants pour qu'ils
acceptent de devenir professeur de
mathématiques quelqu'un qui a une très
bonne formation mathématique peut très
facilement s'engager dans les voiles
ingénieurs danse a également
l'entreprise plutôt que de gagner assez
peu finalement comme professeur même
agrégé justement cette question de la
rémunération jean michel blanchard a
annoncé une hausse de 300 euros bruts
pour les ongs pour les professeurs ainsi
que des primes plus élevées en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire c'est des
solutions convaincantes
ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas des
solutions convaincantes 300 euros
bombard ans pourrait relativiser les
choses bon ça n'attirera pas grand monde
et c'est vraiment le prix d'une petite
pizza comme l'a dit notre président et
national jean rémy girard prévu le pire
alors cela a été officialisée jeudi 5
septembre quatre villes des yvelines ont
reçu le label cité éducative
elles sont 80 en france un projet né
d'une expérimentation à grigny dans le
91 dont l'objectif est d'intensifier les
prises en charge et but éducatif de 0 à
25 ans pendant et autour du cadre
scolaire 34 millions d'euros par an sont
dédiés dans notre département cela
concerne chanteloup les vignes les
mureaux manque
joli et trappes pour l'obtenir chaque
territoire a dû montrer sa détermination
et faire de l'éducation une priorité
une bonne nouvelle de voir des moyens
mis en place pour conforter les actions
réalisées dans ces communes de lantages
de moyens bien sûr c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais pour quoi faire
qu'est ce qu'une cité éducative donc je
peux rappeler que l'ensemble des
professeurs et des syndicats
d'enseignants étaient contre ce projet
pourquoi parce que l'on mélange l'oeil
et maternelle le primaire le collège le
lycée qui sont des enseignements tout à
fait différent ne primaris donc pas le
secondaire ne mélangeons pas les choses
chacun peut faire très bien son travail
dans son cadre alors ces moyens
évidemment sont très bien mais nous
sommes tous mobilisés et s'est pas mis
au point une question de moyens c'est
aussi une question de qualité de
l'enseignement
j'en reviens ce dont on parle tout à
l'heure la réforme c'est le sujet
sensible de cette rentrée scolaire les
réformes la scolarité obligatoire dès 3
ans n'est pas un grand bouleversement
puisque 97 % bien que le 5 les enfants
de cet âge fréquentait déjà l'école en
mais celle qui remue le corps enseignant
c'est cette refonte du baccalauréat
vous vous en souvenez elle avait
entraîné une situation inédite pour
montrer leur opposition 700 correcteurs
ont fait la grève des notes en refusant
de rendre les copies corrigées de
l'examen ce nouveau bac c'est un bac
sans fil hier mais avec un tronc commun
et des options à choisir ainsi que des
changements dans l'examen lui même avec
l'introduction du contrôle continu des
épreuves en mars et un grand oral ou
juin on écoute charline avenel at la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
c'est évidemment une très bonne chose
parce que ça évite le stress
de l'examen ça permet d'échelonner ça
permet d'avoir une progressivité et puis
ça permet à l'ensemble du système de ne
pas être dépendant de ces quelques jours
de la fin juin donc voilà c'est une
c'est une modalité beaucoup plus facile
est vraiment dans l'intérêt des élèves
alors si une réforme dans l'intérêt des
élèves mais je crois qu'elle apporte aux
élèves pour l'instant et aux professeurs
énormément de stress énormément de
désordre dans des établissements c'est
rentré comme je lui ai dit d'entrée de
jeu et une entrée de k o est un ko
aggravé en plus par cette mise en oeuvre
de la réforme
on a dix emplois du temps ne fonctionne
pas on n'arrive pas à faire rentrer la
réforme dans les emplois du temps des
élèves et des professeurs dans les murs
on prévoit maintenant des cours qui
termine à 19 heures certes tous les
autres qui pose problème pour les
emplois du temps
l'éclatement des options est vraiment
quelque chose qui n'est absolument pas
maîtrisé vous avez des des collègues ou
des collègues des et des classes où vous
avez plus de professeurs que d'élèves
une classe par exemple à 45 professeurs
différents parce qu'il ya toute une
folie une folie d'options vous a
vraiment une option tout azimut moment
va se passer ou il ya bien falloir
choisir on n'a pas bhl à dire que la
rectrice parle du bac elle a raison il
ya chauffeur choisira moment sur
l'épreuve du bac est donc les options
vont être réduites
je peux vous citer d'exemples de
collègues qui déjà peu savent que leur
option ne sera pas choisie au bac et qui
entame vraiment en processus
d'inquiétude voire de dépression
justement il y aura des actions tu peux
être mené du quai après cette histoire
de baccalauréat au mois de juillet des
actions sont déjà en cours
vous avez des établissements qu'ils
sentent on crève je ne citerai pas les
établissements vitrine où apparemment
tout s'est bien passé
ou même le champagne a été servi aux
professeurs excellent champ d'ailleurs
ce n'était pas mon établissement
mais des actions sont en cours certains
établissements vont entrer en action
parce qu'il préfère regarder les choses
faire preuve de bonne foi et voir que
les choses ne marchant pas des
établissements ne viennent que de faire
leur rentrée
je parle des lycéens aujourd'hui parce
que les choses ne pouvaient pas
fonctionné il n'y avait pas d'emploi du
temps
à cela donc déjà pris vivement vous avez
des établissements où il manque des
lycées il manque des effectifs
d'encadrement bien savoir que cette
réforme ne vaut que s'il ya suffisamment
de cpe suffisamment de surveillants tout
cela
or ce n'est pas le cas et dans ces
conditions là comment on fait pour
accompagner les élèves justement ils ont
choisi des options faut les accompagner
jusqu'au bac maintenant oui alors je
crois que l'institution peut faire
compris confiance au courage des
professeurs leur art de la
débrouillardise
certains m'ont dit oh je sais ça marche
à peu près en ce moment parce que on se
débrouille on essaye de faire face mais
ça ne peut pas fonctionner on est on est
au bord pour certains établissements du
moment où les professeurs vont faire
tout pour vont à nouveau se mobiliser
des occupations d'établissements haut
lieu certains établissements sont en
grève vous annonçais et d'autres
justement vont se mettre en grève si les
choses ne sont pas résolus là on va
parler d'une autre mesure maintenant la
volonté des cols inclusive avec les
pôles inclusive d'accompagnement
localisés pour gore coordonner les
moyens humains
dix mille élèves en situation de
handicap sont recensés dans les yvelines
cinq mille sont accompagnés avec l'aide
de deux mille accompagnant c'est
suffisant dans l'objectif non ce n'est
pas suffisant l'école inclusive pose
énormément de problèmes beaucoup de
professeurs ne sont pas formés et se
sentent coupables justement dans
certaines situations et surtout ne
sortait pas les culpabiliser parce que
les choses ne marchent pas mais
évidemment le moyen n'est pas suffisant
nous admettons parfaitement que les
enfants qui ont des difficultés
handicapés doivent vivre avec les autres
bienvenu bien sûr accent mis également
sur la numérisation la présidente de
région valérie pécresse a annoncé 150
millions d'euros investis en ile de
france avec notamment les manuels
scolaires disponible en format pdf
numérique
c'était des outils intéressants le
numérique s'applique bien dans
l'enseignement j'attends d'être
convaincu bon dans beaucoup
d'établissements les
je disais de cette réforme a été proposé
mais les professeurs ne l'accepté pas et
s quand ça a été proposé au conseil
d'administration ils ont voté contre
il est arrivé au paradoxe que ceux qui
doivent mettre en herbe en oeuvre cette
réforme du numérique sont ceux qui sont
opposés
écoutez franchement non je ne pense pas
que ce soit un élément de progrès on a
suffisamment dénoncé les méfaits de la
numérisation et du numérique de
téléphones portables tout cela les
facteurs de stress facteurs
d'inattention sont pas l'élément le plus
formateur non c'est beaucoup d'argent
dépensé je pense pas vraiment pour des
buts pédagogique évident d'autre but
pédagogique on en vient au collège le
plan devoirs faits qui s'est déployé sur
tout le territoire
il propose des heures de soutien pour
les aider les aides aux devoirs
c'est une façon peu de combattre les
inégalités face au travail réalisé à la
maison ça fonctionne c'est surtout un
moyen de faire travailler les élèves de
reprendre à bien travailler
c'est très important d'apprendre
progressivement le travail personnel et
rendre son travail régulièrement je suis
tout à fait favorable
frédéric zite vous restez avec nous on
va parler de la rentrée au lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école
l'établissement a accueilli la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des armées geneviève darrieussecq ce
mardi 3 septembre une visite sur fond
d'investissement financier dans ces
établissements mais aussi de prévention
face à d affaire d'harcèlement sur des
étudiantes révélé en 2018
nicolas landry et patrick jacques de
dixmude la secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées geneviève
darrieussecq est arrivé ici au lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école aux
alentours de 15 heures elle a rencontré
des élèves et des enseignants du bts
cyberdéfense une formation à la sécurité
des réseaux informatiques et aux
systèmes embarqués un cursus créé en
l'homme est investi dans ce bts pour
pouvoir remplir les rangs de techniciens
spécialisés dans le cyber dans leur
forme et donc on est formés dans le
domaine de la cyber défense on va
acquérir
comment bien sécurisé des réseaux
informatiques par exemple au site ont
bien protégé notre ordinateur
donc voilà côté programmation ensuite on
a du réseau si le site du système
donc on va vraiment où on a des
compétences globales dans tous les
domaines la secrétaire d'état a aussi
évoqué le plan d'investissement de 100
millions d'euros destinée à la
rénovation des lycées militaires
elle a aussi évoqué les questions de
discriminations et de harcèlement
sexiste dans ces établissements
il faut écouter il faut regarder il faut
dépister il faut voir les signaux
faibles
bien sûr les signaux forts et faire en
sorte de pouvoir prévenir et faire en
sorte surtout s'il y avait le moindre
problème de pouvoir sanctionner
rapidement et bien nous arriverons à
faire en sorte que ces comportement
d'une minorité qui sont inacceptables ne
se reproduise pas près de 800 élèves ont
fait leur rentrée 2019 2020
au lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
des étudiants répartis entre le lycée le
bts et les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles de l'armée
cent deux femmes sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou ex conjoint
depuis le 1er janvier 2019
suite aux multiples actions des proches
des victimes et associations pour
alerter le gouvernement sur ces
féminicide celui ci a annoncé mardi 3
septembre un grenelle des violences
conjugales
il se tiendra jusqu'au 25 novembre avec
notamment des réunions au niveau local
dont les evil la déléguée départementale
aux droits des femmes étaient et à
l'égalité indique qu'une réunion dédiée
aura lieu le 13 septembre prochain les
acteurs de cette lutte contre les
violences conjugales deux départements
seront conviés quatre exemples
d'association s'affiche sur votre écran
les cinquante antennes du centre
d'information pour les droits des femmes
et des familles
l'étincelle l'association dire airwoman
safe
le ministre de l'éducation étaient
présents à ce grenelle il précise que
l'éducation nationale sera totalement
impliqué pour faire avancer la cause de
l'égalité filles garçons et du respect
d'autrui
des réflexions qui sont prises en compte
au sein du corps enseignant comment on
fait pour faire cette prévention là et
bien
- de même je n'ai jamais été formés à
déceler les traces sur un élève d'une
violence parentale
mais ces crimes et ces éléments là
existe et on peut les voir et à ce
moment là il y avait effectivement le
projet de la procédure du signalement le
signalement se fait en référençant se
réfère à sa hiérarchie
donc la procédure existe encore faut-il
voir les signes et les signes ne sont
pas forcément visibles jusqu'au grade et
c est ce qu il ya des modules qui
peuvent être mis en place en cours pour
parler de ces inégalités de prévention
je vous en donne les moyens
pour l'instant donc dont je n'ai pas ma
connaissance de moyens de tellement de
ceux de ce genre là mais bon encore une
fois ci de déceler les signes pas ferait
très utile de le voir on le voit souvent
les enfants viennent vous parler
spontanément vous parler de problèmes
d'un autre après évidemment il faut le
faire la différence entre ce qui est dit
d ce qui est réel parfois beaucoup de
choses raconté qu'ils sont forts c'est
évidemment et on le rappelle le numéro
d'appel d'urgence gratuit dédié le 39 19
on ouvre une page culture à présent avec
cette bonne nouvelle pour le signer 7 à
elancourt déjà labellisées jeune public
et patrimoine et répertoires par
l'association française des cinémas art
et essai il ajoute à son arc la
recherche et découverte
les explications de mélanie poquet
[Musique]
toi
quand on peut
j'ai cependant continué mon rituel
c'est en diffusant des films comme ce
long métrage polonais que le ciné 7 est
aujourd'hui labellisé recherches et
découvertes
une reconnaissance décernée par la fnaca
et l'association française des cinémas
art et essai sont les films peu diffusé
dans les salles cinéma européen cinéma
mondial qui sortent sur des petites
combinaisons de copies très souvent
version originale des films peu diffusé
donc en france voilà peu exposé que le
public a du mal à trouver dans les
salles donc ce cinéma là il faut le
montrer aussi folle exposé il faut le
mettre en lumière et des films découvert
lors de festivals comme celui de cannes
ou par des coups de coeur de l'équipe du
cinéma et du public
ce label est décerné pour les deux
années à venir c'est le troisième que
reçoit le signer cette classé art et
essai depuis 1994 et ça vient couronner
un travail vraiment d'equipe un travail
de programmation réalisée par les
équipes ici sous la houlette de luc
beaucamp et puis c'est un bonne nouvelle
aussi bien entendu pour les spectateurs
qui viennent le voir puisque c'est à la
fois le gage comme j'ai toujours dit
d'un éclectisme culturelle dans ce
cinéma complet on a une palette complète
de toute l'actualité cinématographique
on va bientôt du dollar essais mais ce
sont également les blockbusters il faut
pas les oublier parce qu'on a aussi une
clientèle qui vient pour les voir la
salle élan courtoise projette chaque
année entre 350 et 366 mhz le signer cet
accueil plus de 100000 cinéphiles notre
retour dans le passé de la semaine est
consacrée au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lançait dès
1985 la construction d'un théâtre
d'envergure nationale son talent au
début des années 1990 dans une ville
nouvelle souvent perçu comme un lieu
sans histoire et sans épaisseur humaine
un espace de vie sociale est primordial
visite de l'équipement quelques mois
avant son ouverture
[Musique]
après trois ans de travaux le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'est enfin
ouvert au regard des curieux plutôt
massive et froides à l'extérieur
l'architecturé intérieure choisi par
stanislas fille soeur a séduit de
manière unanime un équipement ou même
les détails ont trouvé leur place au
dessus des 2 salles qui peuvent
accueillir respectivement 1200 et 350
places des appartements ont été
construits pour les artistes des loges
également étudié en fonction des
passages que ce soit des orchestres des
troupes ou des chanteurs bref une
utilisation facilement aménageable pour
toutes les personnes qui vont faire
vivre ce théâtre comme pour le public
qui dispose aussi de lieu d'exposition
reste la programmation et le prix des
places
elle ne devrait pas décevoir non plus il
y aura à 40 spectacles 40 spectacles et
il y aura
du théâtre bien entendu il y aura de la
danse avec des compagnies
internationales et nationales
il y aura
du théâtre musical et lyrique il y aura
aussi un secteur voix ouvert à tous ce
programme présentera également
l'avantagé dès le mois d'octobre
prochain d'être accessible
financièrement à un large public grâce à
des tarifs modérés
une saison qui devrait logiquement
commencé le 2 octobre avec la chanteuse
de jazz dee dee bridgewater
les subventions du sam pour le budget de
fonctionnement du théâtre ayant été
cette semaine
votez en comité syndical
[Musique]
frédéric zaid ces lieux culturels sont
riches dans les villes peuvent compter
dessus vous appuyez dessus dans
l'enseignement tout à fait s'appuyer
dessus dans l'enseignement et le
renseignement n'a pas d'autre but que de
fort l'élève de lui apprendre à se
cultiver de structurer la pensée
d'alimenter sa mémoire puisque vous
savez la culture c'est ce qui reste
quand on a tout oublié
c'est sur ces belles paroles que je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté cette
invitation
bonne rentrée et bas nous rend très bien
si la rue jusqu'à 42 degrés en juillet
les événements aussi ont connu la
canicule et avec elle la sécheresse le
préfet a placé l'ensemble de
départements en situation d' alerte le
23 juillet dernier arrêté non tenue le
21 août
une situation qui impacte encore les
exploitants agricoles mélanie poquet et
patrick jacq des dixmude ils scrutent le
ciel et son téléphone et jérôme regnault
suit deux à trois fois par jour
l'évolution de la météo c'est l'intérêt
plus dur là en effet on va se poser la
question de sortir les charges pour ce
céréalier cette main que les
conséquences de la sécheresse estivales
vont se faire sentir
l'exploitation arrive en période de
labour de préparation des terres pour
les semis l'an passé on était dans des
conditions encore plus difficiles où la
savait vraiment impacté les levées de
colza là on est encore tôt dans la
saison donc il est encore temps que la
pluie arrive et que les potentiels soit
soit là elle les orages du début du mois
d'août n'ont pas changé la situation les
yvelines ont été placés en situation
dallaire sécheresse le 23 juillet par la
préfecture
mais tout n'est pas négatif pour cet
agriculteur l'a pas eu trop d'impact sur
les cultures d'automne
et donc sur le résultat de la moisson en
ça a été bon à très bon pour les
céréales c'est à dire et en quantité et
en qualité
les gras été formé au moment où la
sécheresse et est arrivée la canicule de
fin juin ça a été beaucoup plus
ordinaire à catastrophiques sur les
colzas qui eux avaient subi la
sécheresse de l'été 2018
le mail ça va être particulier en effet
puisqu'il a pris lui le coup de chaud au
moment où il aurait dû être au voire
même commencé cph l'horizon donc lui le
maïs qui sera récolté entre dans la
région c'est souvent entre mi et fin
octobre
on va jusqu'à fin novembre mais souvent
me à fin octobre lui se porte plutôt mal
jérôme regnault exploitent 300 hectares
de terrains où il cultive principalement
des céréales
la pluie est annoncée pour la fin de
semaine avec de rares averses et c'est
la fin de votre édition merci de nous
avoir suivi lundi vous pouvez retrouver
le cette fuite journal ainsi que vos
magazines thématiques qui feront leur
retour
on se quitte avec un extrait du
reportage sur tomates d'eric 1 et nîmes
montrent un qui a traversé le plus grand
désert du sell on good en bolivie
reportage à découvrir dans son
intégralité dès lundi dans votre 7,8
sport bon week-end sur tv 78
je m'apprête à partir
et là c'est réel c'est concret parce
qu'une fois que je serai là dedans je
fais tout seul en totale autonomie sans
gps sans tracker sans balises sans
téléphone satellite
aucun moyen de contacter le reste du
monde donc il y aura que moi et le vide
ça fait quelque chose
[Musique]
orava
e